[موسيقى]
اهلنا الاولين الله يرحمهم لا منهم شافوا
شخص بعد انقطاع طويل يقولون له هل لهلاله
فهي كنايه عن العتب اللطيف زور ورحامكم
ولا تقطعون بهم خاصه بهالشهر الفضيل
والهلال هو الجزء المضاع من حافه القمر
ويكون مثل الظفر ويكون في الاربعه ايام من
الاول والاربعه ايام من الاخيره من الشهر
الهجري يا بدر كم سهرت عليك نواظره ويا
غصن كم ناحت عليك بلا بلو البدر يكمل في
كل شهر مره وهلال وجهك كل يوم
كامل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والاسلام ربط شعائره تعبديه بحركه الاجرام
السماويه فنحن لا نصلي الا على حركات
الشمس اقم الصلاه لدلوك شمس الى غسق الليل
وقران الفجر ان قران الفجر كان مشهودا
ونحن لا نصوم الا على رؤيه القمر صوموا
لرؤيته وافطروا لرؤيته فالشمس والقمر لها
مكانه عظيمه في الشريعه الاسلاميه للشمس
ينبغي لها ان تدرك القمر ولا الليل سابق
النهار وكل في فلك
يسبحون
[موسيقى]